an adult film star a media executive a
fixer all tied to Donald Trump no matter
who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct nearly unsealed court
documents lay out how a web of key
players were involved in the events that
led to the former president being
charged with 34 felony accounts of
falsifying business records Trump has
pleaded not guilty the only crime that I
have committed is to fearlessly defend
our nation from those who seek to
destroy it
here's a list of who's who in this
historic case
[Music]
adult film star Stormy Daniels met Trump
in 2006 at a celebrity golf tournament
where she said he invited her to his
hotel room and you had sex with him yes
you were 27 he was 60 were you
physically attracted to him no
Daniels tried to sell the story of her
alleged sexual encounter with Trump to
Media Outlets multiple times according
to court documents annotated by The Wall
Street Journal former Trump fixer
Michael Cohen covertly paid 130 000 to
Daniels shortly before the election to
prevent her from publicizing a sexual
encounter with Trump Cohen who served as
Trump's personal lawyer at the time was
a key witness before the grand jury that
indicted the former president
court documents say after the election
Trump reimbursed Cohen for the illegal
payment through a series of monthly
checks
Cohen was sentenced to three years in
prison in 2018 after pleading guilty to
nine Federal Criminal counts including
one related to his payment to Daniels Mr
Trump directed me to use my own personal
funds from a home equity line of credit
to avoid any money being traced back to
him
that could negatively impact his
campaign Alan weisselberg the longtime
Chief Financial Officer of the Trump
organization facilitated Cohen's
reimbursement for the payment to Daniels
according to Cohen and federal
prosecutors in order to be able to
um
put it onto the books Alan weisselberg
made the decision
that it should be paid over the 12
months so that it would look like a
retainer weisselberg hasn't commented
publicly about the Madam he pleaded
guilty in an unrelated state tax fraud
case and was sentenced to five months in
jail earlier this year
Berg how do you feel
weisselberg discussed reimbursement for
another hush money payment made in 2016
by David pecker according to Cohen and
prosecutors pecker is the former chief
executive of American Media Incorporated
publisher of the National Enquirer and
appeared twice before the grand jury
court documents say he agreed to help
with Trump's campaign saying that he
would act as the eyes and ears for the
campaign by looking out for negative
stories about Trump and alerting Cohen
before the stories were published in
August 2016 he bought and killed the
story of former Playboy model Karen
McDougall who alleged that she had an
affair with Trump in 2006. the court
documents say Ami ultimately paid 150
000 to McDougall in exchange for her
agreement not to speak about the alleged
sexual relationship good afternoon
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
who took office in January of last year
brought charges against Trump despite
his predecessor deciding not to Bragg
alleges that the former president
repeatedly violated New York's business
records laws in trying to cover up his
payments the charge requires as I as I
specified uh
criminal conduct that was concealed one
of the concealed crimes we allege is New
York state election law
[Music]
it will be set which lawyers and legal
Specialists have said could be pushed
out a year or more putting it squarely
in the 2024 campaign season
[Music]